The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JAMES W. SWAN: So this is
going to be our last lecture
on linear algebra.
The first three
lectures covered basics.
The next three lectures, we
talked about different sorts
of transformations of matrices.
This final lecture is
the last of those three.
We're going to talk about in
another sort of transformation
called the singular
value decomposition.
OK, before we jump in, I'd like
to do the usual recap business.
I think it's always hopeful
to recap or look at things
from a different perspective.
Early on, I told you that the
infinite dimensional equivalent
of vectors would be something
like a function, which
is a map, a unique map maybe
from a point to x to some value
f of x.
And there is an
equivalent representation
of the eigenvalue eigenvector
problem in function space.
We call these eigenvalues
and eigenfunctions.
Here's a classic one where
the function is y of x, OK?
This is the equivalent of
the vector, and equivalent
of the transformation
or the matrix
that's this differential
operator this time,
the second derivative.
So I take the second derivative
of this particular function,
and the function is stretched.
It's multiplied by some
fixed value at all points.
And it becomes lambda times y.
And that operator has to be
closed with some boundary
conditions as well.
We have to say
what the value of y
is at the edges
of some boundary.
So there's a one-to-one
correspondence
between these things.
What is the eigenfunction here,
or what are the eigenfunctions?
And what are the
eigenvalues associated
with this transformation
or this operator?
Can you work those
out really quickly?
You learned this at
some point, right?
Somebody taught you
differential equations
and you calculated these things.
Take about 90 seconds.
Work with the people around you.
See if you can come to
a conclusion about what
the eigenfunction
and eigenvalues are.
That's enough time.
You can work on this
on your own later
if you've run out of time.
Don't worry about it.
Does somebody want
to volunteer a guess
for what the eigenfunctions
are in this case?
What are they?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: OK, so
you chose exponentials.
That's an interesting choice.
That's one possible
choice you can make.
OK, so we could say--
this is sort of a
classical one that you
think about when you first
learn differential equation.
They say, an
equation of this sort
has solutions that look like
exponentials, and that's true.
There's another
representation for this,
which is as trigonometric
functions instead, right?
Either of those is acceptable.
[INAUDIBLE] the
trigonometric functions,
that representation is a
little more useful for us here.
We know that the boundary
conditions tell us that y of 0
is supposed to be 0.
That means that the C1 has to
be 0, because cosine of 0 is 1.
So C1 has 0 in this case.
So that fixes one of
these coefficients.
And now we're left
with a problem, right?
Our solutions, our
eigenfunctions,
cannot be unique.
So we don't get to
specify C2, right?
Any function that's a
multiple of this sine
should also be an eigenfunction.
So instead the other
boundary condition,
this y of l equals 0, needs
to be used to pin down
with the eigenvalue is.
So the second
equation, y of l equals
0, which implies that the
square root of minus lambda
has to be equal
to 2 pi over l, it
has to be all the
nodes of the sine
where the sine is equal to 0.
That's the equivalent of
our secular characteristic
polynomial that prescribes with
the eigenvalues are associated
with each of the eigenfunctions.
So now we know what
the eigenvalues are.
The eigenvalues are
the set of numbers
minus 2 pi n over l squared.
There's an infinite
number of eigenvalues.
It's an infinite dimensional
space that we're in,
so it's not a big surprise
that it works out that way.
And the eigenvectors then are
different scalar multiples
of sine of the eigenvalues,
square root of the eigenvalues,
minus x.
There's a one-to-one
correspondence
between all the linear
algebra we've done
and linear
differential equations
or linear partial
differential equations.
You can think about these
things in exactly the same way.
I'm sure in 1050, you started to
talk about orthogonal functions
to represent solutions of
differential equations.
Or if you haven't, you're
going to very soon.
This is a part of
the course you get
to look at the analytical side
of some of these things as
opposed to the numerical side.
But there's a
one-to-one relationship
between those things.
So if you understand one,
you understand the other,
and you can come at them
from either perspective.
This sort of stuff is useful.
Actually, the classical
chemical engineering example
comes from quantum
mechanics where
you think about wave functions
and different energy levels
corresponding to eigenvalues.
That's cool.
Sometimes, I like to think
about a mechanical analog
to that, which is the
buckling of an elastic column.
So you should do this at home.
You should go get a
piece of spaghetti
and push on the ends of
the piece of the spaghetti.
And the spaghetti will buckle.
Eventually it'll break,
but it'll buckle first.
It'll bend.
And how does it bend?
Well, a balance of linear
momentum on this bar
would tell you
that the deflection
in the bar at different
points x along the bar
multiplied by the pressure has
to balance the bending moment
in the bar itself.
So this e is some
elastic constant.
I has a moment of inertia.
And D squared y dx
squared is something
like the curvature of the bar.
So it's the bending
moments of the bar
that balances the
pressure that's
being exerted on the bar.
And sure enough,
this bar will buckle
when the pressure
applied exceeds
the first eigenvalue associated
with this differential
equation.
We just worked that
eigenvalue out.
We said that that eigenvalue
had to be the square root of 2
pi over l squared.
And so when the pressure
exceeds square root
of 2 pi over l squared
times the elastic modulus,
this column will bend
and deform continuously
until it eventually
breaks, right?
It will undergo this
linear elastic deformation,
then plastic deformation
later, and it will break.
The Eiffel Tower,
actually, is one
of the first
structures in the world
to utilize this
principle, right?
It's got very
narrow beams in it.
The beams are engineered so
that their elastic modulus
is strong enough that
they won't buckle.
Gustave Eiffel is one of the
first applied physicists,
somebody who took the
physics of elastic bars
and applied them to
building structures that
weren't big and blocky, but used
a minimal amount of material.
Cool, right?
OK, so that's recap.
Any questions about that?
You've seen these things before.
You understood them
well before too maybe?
Give some thought to this, OK?
We talked about
eigendecomposition last time
that, associated with
the square matrix,
was a particular eigenvalue or
particular set of eigenvalues,
stretches and corresponding
eigenvectors directions.
These were special solutions to
the system of linear equations
based on a matrix.
It was a square matrix.
And you might ask,
well, what happens
if the matrix isn't square?
What if A is in the space of
real matrices that are n by m,
where n and m maybe
aren't the same?
Maybe they are the same,
but maybe they're not.
And there is an
equivalent decomposition.
It's called the singular
value decomposition.
It's like an eigendecomposition
for non-square matrices.
So rather than writing our
matrix as some w lambda w
inverse, we're going to
write it as some product
U times sigma times
V with this dagger.
The dagger here is
conjugate transpose.
Transpose the matrix, and
take the complex conjugate
of all the elements, OK?
I mentioned last time that
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
could be complex,
potentially, right?
So whenever we have that case
where things can be complex,
usually the
transposition operation
is replaced with the
conjugate transpose.
What are these
different matrices.
Well, let me tell you.
U is a complex matrix.
It maps from the
space N to R N to R N,
so it's an n by n square matrix.
Sigma is a real valued matrix,
and it lives in the space of n
by n matrices.
V is a square matrix again,
but it has dimensions m by m.
Remember, A maps
from R M to R N,
so that's what the
sequence of products says.
B maps from m to m.
Sigma maps from m to n.
U maps from n to n.
So this match from
m to n as well.
Sigma is like
lambda from before.
It's a diagonal matrix.
It only has diagonal elements.
It's just not
square, but it only
has diagonal elements, all
of which will be positive.
And then U and V are called
the left and right singular
vectors.
And they have special
properties associated with them,
which I'll show you right now.
Any questions about
how this decomposition
is composed or made up?
It looks just like the
eigendecomposition,
but it can be applied
to any matrix.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
JAMES W. SWAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Do all
matrices have this thing,
or is it like the eigenvalues
where some do and some don't.
JAMES W. SWAN: This
is a great question.
So all matrices are going
to have a singular value
decomposition.
We saw with the
eigenvalue decomposition
that there could be a case
where the eigenvectors are
degenerate, and we can't
write that full decomposition.
All matrices are going to
have this decomposition.
So for some properties
of this decomposition,
U and V are what we
call unitary matrices.
I talked about these before.
Unitary matrices are ones for
whom, if they're real valued,
their transpose is
also their inverse.
If they're complex
valued, and they're
conjugate transpose is the
equivalent of their inverse.
So U times U conjugate
transpose will be identity.
V times V conjugate
Unitary matrices also
have the property
that they impart no
stretch to a matrix--
or to vectors.
So their maps don't stretch.
They're kind of like
rotational matrices, right?
They change directions, but
they don't stretch things out.
If I were to take A conjugate
transpose and multiply it by A,
that would be the same as taking
U sigma V conjugate transpose,
and multiplying it
by U sigma V. If I
use the properties of
matrix multiplications
and complex
conjugate transposes,
and work out what
this expression is,
I'll find out that it's
equivalent to V sigma conjugate
transpose sigma V
conjugate transpose.
Well this has exactly the same
form as an eigendecomposition.
An eigendecomposition
of A times A instead
of an eigendecomposition
of A. So V
is the set of eigenvectors
of A conjugate transpose A,
and sigma squared
are the eigenvalues
of A conjugate
transpose times A.
And if I reverse the order
of this multiplication--
so I do A times A conjugate
transpose-- and work it out,
that would be U sigma
sigma U. And so U
are the eigenvectors of
A A conjugate transpose,
and sigma squared are still the
eigenvalues of A A conjugate
transpose.
So what are these
things U and V?
They relate to the
eigenvectors of the product
of A with itself, this
particular product of A
with itself, or this particular
product of A with itself.
Sigma are the singular values.
And all matrices possess
this sort of a decomposition.
They all have a set of singular
values and singular vectors.
These sigmas are called the
singular values of the A.
They have a particular name.
I'm going to show you how you
can use this decomposition
to do something you
already know how to do,
but how to do it formally.
What are some properties of the
singular value decomposition?
So if we take a matrix A and
we compute it's singular value
decomposition, this is
how you do it in Matlab.
We'll find out, for this
matrix, U is identity.
Sigma is identity with an
extra column pasted on it.
And B is also identity.
I mean, this is the simplest
possible four by three matrix
I can write down.
You don't have to know how
to compute the singular value
decomposition, you just
need to know that it
can be computed in this way.
You might be able to
guess how to compute it
based on what we did
with eigenvalues earlier
and eigenvectors.
It'll turn out some of
the columns of sigma
will be non-zero right?
There are three non-zero
columns of sigma.
And the columns of
V, they correspond
to those columns of sigma,
spanned the null space
of the matrix A.
So the first three
columns here are non-zero,
the first three columns
of V. I'm sorry,
here are non-zero.
The last column is 0.
The columns of sigma
which are 0 correspond
to a particular column in V,
this last column here, which
lives in the null
space of A. So you
can see, if I take
A and I multiply it
by any vector that's
proportional to 0, 0, 0, 1,
I'll get back 0.
So the null space
of A is spanned
by all these vectors
corresponding
to the 0 columns of sigma.
Some of the columns
of sigma are non-zero.
These first three columns.
And the rows of U corresponding
to those three columns
span the range of A. So
if I do the singular value
decomposition of a matrix,
and I look at U, V, and sigma
and what they're composed of--
where sigma is 0 and non-zero,
and the corresponding columns
or rows of U and V--
then I can figure out
what vectors span the range
and null space of the matrix A.
Here's another example.
So here I have A.
Now instead of being
three rows by four columns,
it's four rows by three columns.
And here's the singular
value decomposition
that comes out of Matlab.
There are no vectors that
live in the null space of A,
and there are no 0
columns in sigma.
There's no corresponding
columns in V.
There are no vectors
in the null space of A.
The range of A is spanned
by the rows corresponding
to the non-zero-- the
rows of U corresponding
to the non-zero
columns of sigma.
So it's these three columns
in the first three rows.
And these first three
rows, clearly they span--
they describe the same range
as the three columns in A.
So the singular
value decomposition
gives us direct access
to the null space
and the range of a matrix.
That's handy.
And it can be used
in various ways.
So here's one example
where it can be used.
Here I have a fingerprint.
It's a bitmap.
It's a square bit of
data, like a matrix,
and each of the
elements of the matrix
takes on a value describing
how dark or light that pixel.
Let's say it's grayscale, and
it's value's between 0 and 255.
That's pretty typical.
So I have this matrix, and
each element to the matrix
corresponds to a pixel.
And I do a singular
value decomposition.
Some of the singular
values, the values of sigma,
are bigger than others.
They're all positive, but
some are bigger than others.
The ones that are
biggest in magnitude
carry the most information
content about the matrix.
So we can do data compression by
neglecting singular values that
are smaller than some
threshold, and also neglecting
the corresponding
singular vectors.
And that's what I've done here.
So here's the original
bitmap of the fingerprint.
I did the singular
value decomposition,
and then I retained only the 50
biggest singular values and I
left all the other
singular values out.
This bitmap was something
like, I don't know,
300 pixels by 300
pixels, so there's
like 300 singular
values, but I got rid
of 5/6 of the
information content.
I dropped 5/6 of the
singular vectors,
and then I
reconstructed the matrix
from the singular values
and those singular vectors,
and you get a faithful
representation
of the original fingerprint.
So the singular
value decomposition
says something about
the information content
in the transformation
that is the matrix, right?
There are some
transformations that
are of lower power or
importance than others.
And the magnitude
of these singular
values tell you what they are.
Does that makes sense?
How else can it be used?
Well, one way it can be
used is finding the least
square solution
to the equation Ax
equals b, where A is no
longer a square matrix, OK?
You've done this
in other contexts
before where the equations
are overspecified.
We have more equations than
unknowns, like data fitting.
You form the normal equations,
you multiply both sides of Ax
equals b by A transpose, and
then invert A transpose A.
You might not be
too surprised, then,
to think that singular value
decomposition could be useful
here too.
Since we already saw the data in
a singular value decomposition
corresponds to eigenvectors and
eigenvalues of this A transpose
A, right?
But there's a way to use
this sort of decomposition
formally to solve
problems that are
both overspecified
and underspecified.
Least squares means find
the vector of solutions
x that minimizes
this function phi.
Phi is the length of the
vector given by the difference
between Ax and b.
It's one measure of how far
an error our solution x is.
So let's define the value
x which is least in error.
This is one definition
of least squares.
And I know the singular value
decomposition of A. So A
is U sigma times V. So I
have U sigma V times x.
I can factor out U, and I've
got a factor of U transpose,
or U conjugate transpose
multiplying by b.
So Ax minus b is the same as
U times the quantity sigma V
conjugate transpose x minus
U conjugate transpose b.
We want to know the x
that minimizes this phi.
It's an optimization problem.
We'll talk in great detail about
these sorts of problems later.
This one is so easy to do,
we can just work it out
in a couple lines of text.
We'll define a new
set of unknowns,
y, which is V transpose times
x, and a new right-hand side
for a system of equations p,
which is U transpose times b.
And then we can rewrite
our function phi
that we're trying to minimize.
So phi then becomes
U sigma y minus p.
U is a unitary vector.
It imparts no stretch in the two
norms, so this sigma y minus p
doesn't get elongated by
multiplication with U.
So it's length,
the length of this,
is the same as the length
of sigma y minus p.
You can prove this.
It's not very difficult
to show at all.
You use the definition of
the two norm to prove it.
So phi is minimized by y's,
which makes this norm smallest,
make it closest to 0.
Let r be the number
of non-zero singular
values, the number
of those sigmas
which are not equal to 0.
That's also the rank of A.
Then I can rewrite
phi as the sum from i
equals 1 to r of sigma i i
time y i minus p i squared.
That's parts of this length,
this Euclidean length,
for which sigma is non-zero.
Plus the sum from r
plus 1 to n, the sum
over the rest of
the values of p,
for which the
corresponding sigmas are 0.
I want to minimize
phi, and the only thing
that I can change to
minimize it is what?
What am I free to
pick in this equation
in order to make phi
as small as possible?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: y.
JAMES W. SWAN: y,
so I need to choose
the y's that make this
phi as small as possible.
What value should I
choose for the y's?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: Perfect, right?
Choose y equals p
i over sigma i i.
Right, y i is p
Then all of these terms is 0.
I can't make this sum
any smaller than that.
That fixes the value
of y i up to r.
I can't do anything about
this left over bit here.
There's no choice of
y that's going to make
this part and the smaller.
It's just left over.
It's some remainder that
we can't make any smaller
or minimize an smaller.
There isn't an exact solution
to this problem, in many cases.
But one way this could be
0 is if r is equal to n.
Then there are left
over unspecified terms,
and then this y i
equals p i over sigma i
is the exact solution
to the problem.
So this is what you told me.
Choose y i is p i over sigma i i
for i bigger than 1 and smaller
than r.
There are going to
be values of y i
that go between r plus 1 and
m, because A was a vector that
mapped from m to n, right?
So I have extra values of y that
could be specified potentially.
If that's true, if r
plus 1 is smaller than m,
then there's some components
of y that I don't get to--
I can't specify, right?
My system of equations is
somehow underdetermined.
I need some external
information to show me what
values to pick for those y i.
I don't know.
I can't use them.
Sometimes people just
set y i equal to 0.
That's sort of silly,
but that's what's done.
It's called the minimum
norm least square solution.
y has minimum length, when you
set all these other components
to 0.
But the truth is, we can't
specify those components,
right?
We need some
external information
in order to specify them.
Once we know y, we
can find x going back
to our definition of what y is.
So I multiply this equation
by V on both sides,
and I'll get V y equals x.
So I can find my
least square solution
to the problem from the
singular value decomposition.
So I can find the
least square solution
to both overdetermined and
underdetermined problems using
singular value decomposition.
It inherits all
the properties you
know of solving the
normal equations,
multiplying by A transpose
the entire equation,
and solving for a least
square solution that way.
But that's only good for
overdetermined systems
of equations.
This can work for
underdetermined equations
as well.
And maybe we do have
extraneous information
that lets us specify these
other components somehow.
Maybe we do a
separate optimization
that chooses from all
possible solutions
where these y i's are free,
and picks the best one subject
to some other constraint.
Does it makes sense?
OK, that's the
last decomposition
we're going to talk about.
It's as expensive to compute
the singular value decomposition
as it is to solve a
system of equations.
You might have
guessed that it's got
an order N cubed flavor to it.
It's kind of inescapable
that we run up
against those
computational difficulties,
order N cubed
computational complexity.
And there are many problems
of practical interest,
particularly solutions of
PDEs, for which that's not
going to cut it.
Where you couldn't solve
the problem with that sort
of scaling in time.
You couldn't compute the
Gaussian elimination,
or the singular
value decomposition,
or an eigenvalue decomposition.
It won't work.
And in those cases, we appeal
to not exact solution methods,
but approximate
solution methods.
So instead of trying to
get an exact solution,
we'll try to formulate
one that's good enough.
We already know the computer
introduces numerical error
anyways.
Maybe we don't need machine
precision in our solution
or something close to machine
precision in our solution.
Maybe we're solving
engineering problem,
and we're willing to
accept relative errors
on the order of 10 to the
minus 3 or 10 to the minus 5,
some specified tolerance
that we apply to the problem.
And in those circumstances,
we use iterative methods
to solve systems of
equations instead
of exact methods,
elimination methods,
or metrics
decomposition methods.
These algorithms are all
based on iterative refinement
of an initial guess.
So if we have some
system of equations
we're trying to
solve, Ax equals b,
we'll formulate some
linear map, right?
xi plus 1 will be some
matrix C times x i
plus some little vector c
where x i is my last best
guess for the solution to
this problem, and x i plus 1
is my next best guess for
the solution to this problem.
And I'm hoping, as I apply
this map more and more times,
I'm creeping closer
to the exact solution
to the original
system of equations.
The map will converge
when x i plus 1
approaches x i, when the
map isn't making any changes
to the vector anymore.
And the converged value will
be a solution when x i--
which is equal to i
minus c inverse times c,
if I replace x i was
1 with x i appear,
so I say that my map has
converged-- when this value is
equivalent to A
inverse times B, when
it's a solution to the
original problem, right?
So my map may converge.
It may not converge to a
solution of the problem I like,
but if it satisfies
this condition,
then has converged to be
a solution of the problem
that I like as well.
And so it's all about using this
C here and this little c here
so that this map converges
to solution of the problem
I'm after.
And there are lots of
schemes for doing this.
Some of them are kind of ad hoc.
I'm going to show
you one right now.
And then when we
do optimization,
we'll talk about
a more formal way
of doing this for
which you can guarantee
very rapid convergence
to a solution.
So here's a system of
equations I'd like to solve.
It's not a very big one.
It doesn't really make sense
to solve this one iteratively,
but it's a nice illustration.
One way to go about
formulating this map
is to split this
matrix into two parts.
So I'll split it into a diagonal
part and an off diagonal part.
So I haven't changed the
problem at all by doing that.
And then I'm going to
rename this x x i plus 1,
and I'm going to
rename this x x i.
And then move this
matrix vector product
to the other side
of the equation.
And here's my map.
Of course, this
matrix multiplied
doesn't make any-- it's
not useful to write it out
explicitly.
This is just identity.
So I can drop this entirely.
This is just x i plus one.
So here's my map.
Take an initial guess,
multiply it by this matrix,
add the vector 1, 0, and repeat
over and over and over again.
Hopefully-- we
don't really know--
but hopefully, it's
going to converge
to a solution of the
original linear equations.
I didn't make up that method.
That's a method called
Jacobi Iteration.
And the strategy is to split
the matrix A into two parts--
a sum of its diagonal
elements, and it's off diagonal
elements--
and rewrite the original
equations as an iterative map.
So D times x i plus 1 is equal
to minus r times x i plus b.
Or x i plus 1 is D inverse
times minus r x i plus b.
If the equations converge,
then D plus r times x i
has to be equal to b, we
will have found a solution.
If it converges, right?
If these iterations
approach a steady value.
If they don't change from
iteration to iteration.
Is
The nice thing about
the Jacobi method is it
turns the hard
problem, the order
N cubed problem of
computing A inverse B,
into a succession
of easy problems,
D inverse times some vector C.
How many calculations does it
take to compute that D inverse?
N, that's right, order N.
It's just a diagonal matrix.
I invert each of its diagonal
elements, and I'm done.
So I went from order N cubed,
which was going to be hard,
into a succession
of order N problems.
So as long as it doesn't
take me order N squared
iterations to get to the
solution that I want,
I'm going to be OK.
This is going to be
a viable way to solve
this problem faster than
finding the exact solution.
How do you know
that it converges?
That's the question.
Is this thing actually
going to converge or not,
or are these iterations just
going to run on and on forever?
Well, one way to check whether
it will converge or not
is to go back up to this
equation here, and substitute b
equals Ax, where x is the
exact solution to the problem.
And you can transform,
then, this equation into one
that looks like x i plus
1 minus x equal to minus D
inverse times r x i minus x.
And if I take the
norm of both sides
and I apply our
normal equality--
where the norm of a
matrix vector product
is smaller than the product
of the norms of the matrices
of the vectors--
then I can get a
ratio like this.
That the absolute error
in iteration I plus 1
divided by the absolute
error in iteration i
is smaller than the
norm of this matrix.
So if I'm converging,
then what I expect
is this ratio should
be smaller than 1.
The error in my
next approximation
should be smaller than the error
in my current approximation.
That makes sense?
So that means that I would hope
that the norm of this matrix
is also smaller than 1.
If it is, then I'm going to
be guaranteed to converge.
So for a particular
coefficient matrix,
for a system of linear
equations I'm trying to solve,
I may be able to find--
I may find that this is true.
And then I can
apply this method,
and I'll converge to a solution.
We call this sort of
convergence linear.
Whatever this number
is, it tells me
the fraction by which the
error is reduced from iteration
to iteration.
So suppose this is 1/10.
Then the absolute error is going
to be reduced by a factor of 10
in each iteration.
It's not going to
be 1/10 usually.
It's going to be
something that's
a little bit bigger than that
typically, but that's the idea.
You can show-- I would encourage
you to try to work this out
on your own-- but you can show
that the infinity norm of this
product--
infinity norm of this
product is equal to this.
And if I ask that the
infinity norm of this product
be smaller than 1,
that's guaranteed
when the diagonal values of
the matrix and absolute value
are bigger than
the sum of the off
diagonal values in a particular
row or a particular column.
And that kind of matrix we
call diagonally dominant.
The diagonal values are bigger
than the sum and absolute value
of the off diagonal pieces.
So diagonally dominant matrices,
which come up quite often,
can be-- those linear
equations based
on those matrices can be solved
reasonable efficiency using
the Jacobi method.
There are better
methods to choose.
I'll show you one in a second.
But you can guarantee
that this is
going to converge to a solution,
and that the solution will
be the right solution to
the linear equations you
were trying to solve.
So if the goal is just to
turn hard problems into easier
to solve problems, then
there are other natural ways
to want to split a matrix.
So maybe you want to split into
A lower triangular part which
contains the diagonal
elements of A,
and an upper
triangular part which
has no diagonal elements of A.
We just split this thing apart.
And then we could rewrite
our system of equations
is an iterative map
like this, L times x i
plus 1 is minus U
times x i plus b.
All I have to do is invert
l to find my next iteration.
And how expensive
computationally
is it to solve a system of
equations which is triangular?
This is a process we
call back substitution.
Its order--
AUDIENCE: N squared.
JAMES W. SWAN: --N squared.
So we still beat N cubed.
One would hope that it doesn't
require too many iterations
to do this.
But in principle, we can do
this order N squared operations
many times.
And it'll turn out
that this sort of a map
converges to the solution
that we're after.
It converges when matrices
are either diagonally dominant
as before, or they're symmetric
and they're positive definite.
Positive definite means all
the eigenvalues of the matrix
are bigger than 0.
So try the iterative method
solving some equations
and see how we convert.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you justify
ignoring the diagonal elements
in that method?
JAMES W. SWAN: So
the question was,
how do you justify ignoring
the diagonal elements
in this method.
Maybe I was going too
fast or I misspoke.
So I'm going to split A into
a lower triangular matrix that
has all the diagonal
elements, and U
is the upper parts with none of
those diagonal elements on it.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAMES W. SWAN: Thank you
for asking that question.
I hope that's clear.
l holds onto the diagonal
pieces and U takes those away.
So let's try it.
On a matrix like this,
the exact solution
to this system of equations
is 3/4, 1/2, and 1/4.
All right, we'll
try Jacobi, we'll
have to give it some initial
guess for the solution, right?
We're talking about
places where you
can derive those initial guesses
from later on in the course,
but we have to start
the iterative process
with some guess
at the solutions.
So here's an initial guess.
We'll apply this map.
Here's Gauss-Seidel with
the same initial guess,
and we'll apply this map.
They're both
linearly convergent,
so the relative
error will go down
by a fixed factor
after each iteration.
Iteration one, the relative
error in Jacobi will be 38%.
In Gauss-Seidel, it'll be 40%.
If we apply this all the
way down to 10 iterations,
the relative error Jacobi will
be 1.7%, and the relative error
in Gauss-Seidel 0.08%.
And we can go on and on
with these iterations
if we want until we get
sufficiently converged, we
get to a point where the
relative error is small enough
that we're happy to accept
this answer as a solution
to our system of equations.
So we traded the burden of doing
all these calculations to do
elimination for a faster,
less computationally complex
methodology.
But the trade off was we don't
get an exact solution anymore.
We're going to have finite
precision in the result,
and we have to
specify the tolerance
that we want to converge to.
We're going to see now-- this
is the hook into the next part
of that class--
we're going to talk about
solutions of nonlinear
equations next for
which there are
almost no non-linear equations
that we can solve exactly.
They all have to be solved
using these iterative methods.
You can use these iterative
methods for linear equations.
It's very common
to do it this way.
In my group, we
solve lots of systems
of linear equations associated
with hydrodynamic problems.
These come up when
you're talking about,
say, low Reynolds
number flows, which
are linear sorts of
fluid flow problems.
They're big.
It's really hard to do
Gaussian elimination,
so you apply different
iterative methods.
You can do Gauss-Seidel.
You can do Jacobi.
We'll learn about
more advanced ones
like PCG, which you're
applying on your homework now,
and you should be seeing that
it converges relatively quickly
in cases where exact
elimination doesn't work.
We'll learn, actually,
how to do that method.
That's one that we
apply in my own group.
It's pretty common
to use out there.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One question, is
that that Gauss, [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: Order N squared.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that's what I meant.
So now we've got an [INAUDIBLE].
So we basically have
[INAUDIBLE] iterations, right?
JAMES W. SWAN: This is
a wonderful question.
So this is a pathological
problem in the sense
that it requires a
lot of calculations
to get an iterative
solution here.
We haven't gotten
to an end that's
big enough that the
computational complexities
crossover.
So for small Ns, probably
the factor in front of N--
whatever number that is--
and maybe even the
smaller factors,
order N squared
factors on that order
N cubed, play a big
role in how long
it takes to actually
complete this thing.
But modern problems are so
big that we almost always
are running out to Ns
that are large enough
that we see a crossover.
You'll see this in your
homework this week.
You won't see this
crossover at N equals 3.
You're going to see
it out at N equals
500 or 1,200, big problems.
Then we're going to
encounter this crossover.
That's a wonderful question.
So first small system
sizes, iterative methods
maybe don't buy you much.
I suppose it depends on the
application though, right?
If you're doing something
that involves solving problems
on embedded hardware, in some
sort of sensor or control
valve, there may be
very limited memory
or computational capacity
available to you.
And you may actually
apply an iterative method
like this to a problem
that that controller
needs to solve, for example.
It just may not
have the capability
of storing and inverting what
we would consider, today,
a relatively small matrix
because the hardware doesn't
have that sort of capability.
So there could be
cases where you
might choose something
that's slower but feasible,
versus something that's
faster and exact,
because there are
other constraints.
They do exist, but modern
computers are pretty efficient.
Your cell phone is faster
than the fastest computers
in the world 20 years ago.
We're doing OK.
So we've got to get out to
big system sizes, big problem
sizes, before this
starts to pay off.
But it does for many
practical problems.
OK I'll close with this, because
this is the hook into solving
nonlinear equations.
So I showed you these
two iterative methods,
and they kind of had
stringent requirements
for when they were actually
going to converge, right?
I had to have a diagonally
dominant system of equations
for Jacobi to converge.
I had to have diagonal dominance
or symmetric positive definite
matrices.
These things exist
and they come up
in lots of physical
problems, but I
had to have it in order for
Gauss-Seidel to converge.
What if I have a
system of equations
that doesn't work that way?
Or what if I have
an iterative map
that I like for some reason, but
it doesn't appear to converge?
Maybe it converges under some
circumstances, but not others.
Well, there's a way to modify
these iterative maps, called
successive
over-relaxation, which
can help promote convergence.
So suppose we have an
iterative map like this, x i
plus 1 is some function of
the previous iteration value.
Doesn't matter what it is.
It could be linear,
could be non-linear.
We don't actually care.
The sought after solution
is found when x i plus 1
is equal to x i.
So this map is one
the convergence
to the exact solution of
the problem that we want.
We've somehow guaranteed
that that's the case,
but it has to converge.
One way to modify that
map is to say x i plus 1
is 1 minus some
scalar value omega
times x i plus omega times f.
You can confirm that if you
substitute x i plus 1 equals
x i into this equation,
you'll come up
with the same fixed points
of this iterative map
x i is equal to f of x i.
So you haven't changed what
value will converge here,
but you've affected the
rate at which it converges.
Here you're saying x i
plus 1 is some fraction
of my previous solution plus
some fraction of this f.
And I get to control how big
those different fractions.
So if things aren't converging
well for a map like this,
then I could try
successive over-relaxation,
and I could adjust this
relaxation parameter
to be some fraction, some
number between 0 and 1,
until I start to
observe convergence.
And there are some
rules one can use
to try to promote
convergence with this kind
of successive over-relaxation.
This is a very generic
technique that one can apply.
If you have any iterative
map you're trying to apply,
it should go to the
solution you want
but it doesn't converge
for some reason,
then you can use this
relaxation technique to promote
convergence to the solution.
You may slow the
convergence way down.
It may be very slow to
converge, but it will converge.
And after all, an
answer is better
than no answer, no matter
how long it takes to get it.
So sometimes you've
got to get these things
by hook or by crook.
So for example, you can
apply this to Jacobi.
This was the
original Jacobi map.
And we just take that.
We add 1 minus omega
times x i plus omega
times this factor over here.
And now we can choose omega so
that this solution converges.
We always make omega
small enough so
that the diagonal
values of our matrix
appear big enough
that the matrix looks
like it's diagonally dominated.
You could go back to that
same convergence analysis
that I showed you before
and try to apply it
to this over-relaxation
form of Jacobi and see that,
while there's always going to
be some value of omega that's
small enough, that this
thing will converge.
It will look effectively
diagonally dominant,
because omega inverse
times D will be big enough,
or omega times D inverse
will be small enough.
Does that make sense?
You can apply the same sort of
damping method to Gauss-Seidel
as well.
It's very common to do this.
The relaxation parameter acts
like an effective increase
in the eigenvalues
of the matrix.
So you can think about L. That's
a lower triangular matrix.
It's diagonal values
are its eigenvalues.
The diagonal values
of L inverse--
well, 1 over those
diagonal values
are the eigenvalues
of L inverse.
And so if we make
omega very small,
then we make the eigenvalues
of L inverse very small,
or the eigenvalues
or L very big.
And again, the matrix starts
to look diagonally dominated.
And you can promote
convergence in this way.
So even though this
may be slow, you
can use it to
guarantee convergence
of some iterative procedures,
not just for linear equations,
but for non-linear
equations as well.
And we'll see,
there are good ways
of choosing omega
for certain classes
of non-linear equations.
We'll apply
Newton-Raphson method,
and then will damp it using
exactly the sort of procedure.
And I'll show you
how you can choose
a nearly optimal value for
omega to promote convergence
to the solution.
Any questions?
No, let me address one
more thing before you go.
We've scheduled times
for the quizzes.
They are going to
be in the evenings
on the dates that are
specified on the syllabus.
We wanted to do them
during the daytime.
It was really
difficult to schedule
a room that was big
enough for this class,
so they have to be from 7:00
to 9:00 in the gymnasium.
I apologize for that.
We spent several days
looking around trying
to find a place where
we could put everybody
so you would all get the
same experience in the quiz.
I know that the November
quiz comes back to back
with the thermodynamics
exam as well.
That's frustrating.
Thermodynamics is the next day.
That week is tricky.
That's AICHE, so most of
the faculty have to travel.
We won't be able
to teach, but you
won't have classes
one of those days
so you have extra time to study.
And Columbus Day also
falls in that week,
so there's no way to put
three exams in four days
without having them
come right back to back.
Believe me, we
thought about this
and tried to get things
scheduled as efficiently as we
could for you, but
sometimes there
are constraints that are
outside of our control.
But the quiz times are set.
There's going to be done in
October and one in November.
They'll be in the evening, and
they'll be in the gymnasium.
I'll give you directions
to it before the exam, just
say you know exactly
where to go, OK?
Thank you, guys.